coach k joins us now along with our
special correspondent that's james brown
hey james brown good to see you gl
really glad you're here
coach k let me just say this you're a
very big deal because
james brown is in the house early to get
up to talk to you so weird
no i know we are all excited we're all
excited that you're here
you know i watched your news conference
yesterday and it struck me when you said
as a coach it's not about having a run
it's about having a finish
you have certainly had a great run and
the finish is still to be determined
but take us in the family conversation
about why you all decided and i heard
you say it was a family decision
that now was a time take us with you and
mickey and your daughters
well it's been a family decision from
19 1975 when i got to be the head coach
at west point
and and then in 1980 to to for duke and
now
uh were my daughters uh they weren't all
there at each time
my three daughters we we call us
ourselves to starting five and when we
make
when we make decisions like this uh
we sit down as a family the person the
main person knows my wife mickey and
we've talked about this for the last
couple years but
we knew this spring that we
were ready and but we wanted to coach
one more year and we also
wanted to have a succession plan so that
the
program would continue to you know to
compete at a high level and so
today my top assistant john shire will
be named a coach and head coach in
waiting and
he'll take over hopefully after we make
a
have so we have a great season we'll
we'll talk about that in just a second
right now we want to focus on you coach
k
i reached out to some members of your
brotherhood grant hill last night who
talked to me right before he had to work
the uh sons lakers game and billy king
and they said this about you grant said
we all knew this day was coming but it
was still emotional
you taught responsibility accountability
and love
your brilliance was getting people to
believe and believe in one another you
were more than just an incredible
professor it wasn't just about x's and
o's
billy king said this you made everybody
feel important
you could be demanding you wanted your
players to get it right you yelled and
hugged
and you knew when to do both your thing
about leadership was
it was all about relationships because
when you have relationships you can lead
do they have that right about you i was
very touched by
what the comments they made about you
well
they have in essence what's right and it
is about relationships they
used a lot of nice words i think they're
vying for playing time they forgot that
their eligibility is up
but uh now it's about
developing a relationship individually
and then a relationship
with the with the team and it has to be
based on trust
now there's a lot of emotion when you do
this
and there are hugs wow
i can't wait to get back to that we
weren't able to do much of that this
past season
yeah and uh but some of it is you know
to push
people to their potential it's not just
about hugs it's about
getting on them sometimes and and when
you do
they know that that they they trust you
it's not personal
and uh with billy and uh grant those two
guys were
not just exceptional players they were
exceptional leaders and and
men and they be they become great men
which
i think is the best accomplishment a
coach can have
hey james hey mike i think about uh me
having played for the coach
k at the high school level and morgan
wooten who took a lot of notes
from you and he talked about the
basketball court being an extension of
his classroom
your high school coach and teacher who
made a palpable
impact on you what lessons did you learn
from them mike
well coach ostrowski passed away in the
last year and
he was not that much older he was in his
early 20s and
he i thought i was good and he thought i
was better
and so what i learned from him is that
a belief you know i went up to a certain
point and then you start questioning
he made me not question and the ability
for somebody to do
that you know made an impact on me that
i wanted to be able to do that
and as a result too james i i i
it's one of my one of the things i do in
coaching i coach my best player the
hardest
and that's what he did for me and it had
great dividends and
it's had great dividends you know for
the 46 years i've been a head coach
coach k thank you so much please know we
are cheering you on